so the movie opens with morbius going to
a bad infested cave in south america i
think to offer up his blood however this
opening is kind of just a hook to draw
on the viewers because it immediately
cuts to a flashback of a young morbius
in this scene we meet milo who shares
the same blood disease as morbius and
randomly out of nowhere milo's machine
that helps his blood malfunctions and
somehow morbius is able to repair it the
writers brush it off with morbius just
being gifted and that doesn't really
explain the fact that this kid shouldn't
know how to fix a complicated machine
that was made by professionals i feel
like there could have been a more
natural way to introduce his
intelligence but whatever he's smart
through the sequence we kind of speed
run development since morbius gets
shipped off to a gifted school for
repairing something with a spring and he
leaves milo a letter while reading it
the wind magically swoops it up and
takes it away forcing milo to go outside
where some bullies are this is a weird
and contrived way to get milo to go
outside on top of the fact that there is
no shot he'll be able to find his note
given that it'll take him a long time to
get out of the building with his
disorder but magically the wind doesn't
touch it once it hits the floor after
catching up to his elusive note he
engages in a violent encounter and for
some reason other kids hate crippled
children which is just a weird form of
conflict it seems like the writers are
trying to get the backstory done as fast
as possible at the cost of the pace in
the writing quickly going to the present
day we find an older morbius receiving
an award for his development of
artificial blood
and right away you can just tell that
they're going to use this as a cop-out
to avoid the fact that morbius will need
to drink blood since he becomes a
vampire later on a very convenient way
to make the character more of a good guy
while deleting the conflict and having
to potentially kill innocent people for
blood after a day at work where morbius
discovers that mixing bat dna with my
cna successfully works he stops him to
hang out with his old friend milo and
like a true friend milo tells morbius
that he should never fall in love with
other people because milo reads books in
which love doesn't work out i read about
it in books all the time books really
yeah wow this is kind of a weird
conversation point because these are
supposed to be long time friends and he
should be encouraging his friend to find
love for the short time they have left
instead of selfishly trying to influence
him to hang out with himself seems kind
of manipulative and selfish but hey
don't judge getting to the point of the
scene though morbius says he wants to do
an all-in play by mixing their dna with
a bat since it worked on a mouse which
that kind of makes sense because they
are desperate for time however i feel
like it's even riskier to not conduct
more experiments before diving into the
deep end but hey we don't want a boring
movie of a scientist going through the
scientific method let's get to the good
[ __ ]
since it's illegal to do this procedure
morbius decides to do it on a freighter
in international waters
after the procedure morbius gets his
powers and for some reason there's a
group of mercenaries on board i don't
really know why they're here and i feel
like the writers just wanted a forced
action scene to introduce morbius's new
powers and i kind of feel bad for them
because these are guys trying to defend
themselves from a terrifying and
dangerous monster also before this
action scene starts the mercenaries
throw morbius's scientists friends and
potential love interests martine to the
ground which knocks her out since she
was trying to stop them so morbius now
has motivation to kill these people the
following action is pretty dark and
violent but is clearly hidden and muted
because of the pg-13 rating like a guy
got his throat cut open and bled out and
blood got splattered on screen multiple
times so it's weird that this movie
isn't rated r and it's clearly because
sony wanted a larger demographic to be
able to see the movie at the expense of
fully committing to a darker and more
violent movie and actually showing
what's happening after the action scene
morbius turns back to a more human form
and i find it kind of weird how he
spontaneously got a six-pack from
becoming a super vampire i don't think
that's technically a part of his
powerless but alright i'll roll with
that so morbius broadcasts a mayday
signal and jumps overboard and goes back
to his lab in new york and guess what
that mcguffin artificial blood invention
that was introduced earlier comes back
and now morbius can drink it without
harming anyone leaving his moral
conscience uncorrupted besides that
group of mercenaries he brutally killed
the writers do set up that this isn't a
permanent solution because he's getting
deteriorating returns from drinking
artificial blood however this doesn't
really end up mattering because the
story doesn't last long enough for
morbius to run out of artificial blood
moving along though during some
endurance tests miles shows up to the
lab looking for morbius and he asked him
for the quote unquote cure and instead
of going into the details as to why the
cure is terrible and is a curse morbius
just briefly says it's really bad and
alienates his best friend like it could
have been really easy to explain to him
and convince him why he shouldn't take
it but i assume the writers are leading
to milo becoming a villain so it comes
across as a contrivance later on a poor
nurse gets jumped by a vampire which
puzzles morbius when he finds out about
the news hmm i wonder who that could be
morbius hopefully makes the same
connection and is about to leave the
building until being stopped by two
detectives looking into his case since
the boat incident they figure out that
another body there has been drained of
blood so just before they arrest him
morbius runs for it and by that i mean
he flies up his cereal and makes it to
the roof while up there he gets swept
away in some terrible visual effects
which i guess is supposed to be wind and
somehow one of the detectives made it to
the rooftop in 20 seconds flat by
climbing the stairs like that's
literally impossible and it's hilarious
to me that this wasn't rewritten then
the detective pulls a gun on morbius and
it cuts to him in prison which again
immediately doesn't make any sense
because just 10 seconds prior morbius
was able to dodge a bullet so i don't
know how he wasn't able to keep running
for it but whatever i guess the writers
couldn't come up with a better way to
have morbius detained or let alone the
plot point being logical by any degree
while in prison milo passes as morbius
lawyer and gives him a packet of blood
before he leaves which wouldn't be
possible because you're supposed to
empty all of your belongings before
meeting with a prisoner or going through
security in general especially one
that's a prime suspect in murder then
milo leaves and forgets his cane that he
walked in with to give morbius the idea
that he took the cure and it's also
funny that a guard is completely fine
with milo giving morbius a potential
weapon or the guard is terrible with
their job and didn't catch that so as a
result of this marvius breaks out of
prison and tracks mile down with his
echolocation he finds him on a sidewalk
buying a newspaper from someone who kind
of says something negative about morbius
which is definitely justified since he's
tied to killing a bunch of mercenaries
because of this milo gets mad at him for
talking bad about his friends and kills
them out in the open that seems like a
terrible idea given that they were in a
brightly lit area with people walking
around and i guess this also means that
milo is a cold-blooded killer now
was this because he was bullied as a kid
i genuinely don't know morbius son
confronts him and milo says that for the
nurse in particular he didn't have
control but that's irrelevant because he
just killed an innocent bystander like
one minute ago then they go through the
stereotypical dialogue of this isn't who
you are i know you you're a good person
then they get physical and some cops try
to stop them to which milo kills them
and dances over their corpses and says
this all our life we lived with death
hanging over us
why shouldn't they know what it feels
like this motivation is completely
devoid of logic firstly it's not the
fault of these innocent people as to why
you had a blood disease and secondly
flat out killing them doesn't achieve
your supposed objective of making them
feel like you did you're just murdering
them so milo just becomes a crazy
psychopath with practically no buildup
other than that one small moment from
his childhood of getting bullied i guess
he held on to that pent-up aggression
for his entire life morbius figures out
how to harness the weird vfx wind caused
by a train and flies down the subway
escaping from having to fight milo to
quickly recap a bit of time goes by
where there's a scene with the
detectives discovering the cops morbius
meeting with martine and morbius finding
some illegal operation and scaring them
away so we could turn it into a lab then
we have a weird dancing scene with milo
that will have doctor who fans drooling
i feel bad for matt smith because he
probably had to get ripped and worked
out for months just for this one scene
this leads into milo going to a bar
where he hits on a lady and some guys
yell at him for whatever reason so milo
goes outside and waits for them to come
out so he can kill them these last five
minutes as a whole feel pretty much
pointless to the movie and is overall
redundant because prior to this milo
killed a bunch of cops so why show him
in another extended scene killing even
more people by himself they later
excused this as there being a security
camera in the parking lot so now people
know there's another killer on the loose
but he could have achieved the same
thing by there being a security camera
in the subway to avoid redundancy after
this milo visits martine to try and
figure out where morbius is she ends up
lying to him but he knows she's lying
because he has super hearing and he can
hear her heartbeat as a result he
follows her to morbius's hideout and
while there they decide to conveniently
leave their hideout and go to the
rooftop to kiss this all happens just so
that milo can witness this happen and
it's extremely awkward i couldn't help
but laugh at the face milo makes while
watching them milo goes home and the
doctor that's been taking care of him
all his life confronts him and
reasonably is repulsed by what he's done
and has become he doesn't do anything
wrong to milo and he kills him
regardless so at this point i'm kind of
just disconnected to the villain and
what his ideals are his objectives and
how he's changed significantly when in
comparison morbius has stayed the same
character after taking the cure because
of his violent wicked nature milo
kidnaps martine to try and lure morbius
over to him before he gets there milo
kills martine as she's about to die a
horny morbius bends over and starts to
make out with her which is very weird
and off-putting angered by the death of
martine milo and morbius are propelled
into a mind-numbing final fight scene
where you literally can't see anything
the editing is extremely jarring the set
piece is made up of only darkness the
vfx is atrocious as usual and because of
all of this the filmmakers decide to
throw in random slow-mo shots so the
audience can actually tell what's going
on and after three brain-bleeding
minutes of action they fall through the
ground as if it was made of paper mache
and make their way into the subway
morbius calls for some bats and then
comedically fall to the ground then
somehow like thousands of bats
materialize out of nowhere to aid
morbius in fighting milo firstly there's
no way there's this many bats casually
hanging around in the underground
network of new york and secondly he can
now control bats and uses them to attack
milo i guess the writers made that up
because according to his list of powers
that doesn't exist or at least what i'm
seeing in his wiki and i also don't know
how all these bats somehow gave morbius
enough energy to rise up again was it
just a confidence boost uh what really
nothing makes sense about this and there
are so many bats flying around on the
screen that it's giving me a headache
this entire sequence feels like a
nightmare fever dream and i feel sorry
for any kid who went to go see this
movie in the movie theater so yeah
that's basically the end of the movie
and he may be thinking hey vulture was
in the trailer right where is he he
hasn't shown up yet well you're in luck
because he's only in the end credits
scene apparently he came from the mcu
when the multiverse was cracking open in
spider-man no way home and that
immediately contradicts what happens in
no way home because the whole point of
that was people who knew spider-man were
being teleported to that universe so
vulture randomly gets sent into the
universe with morbius
yeah
i don't even think the writers know why
he's here then there's a second end
credit scene where vulture now
miraculously has all his gear back and
in the scene he meets up with morbius
and asks to team up and we all know that
isn't going to happen and i don't know
if this is some kind of sinister six
build up uh yeah i don't know i thought
most of you guys have seen this movie so
you're welcome i jumped on the grenade
so you could watch the summary of the
most stupid moments in the movie thank
you for watching and have a great day
and please watch a better movie than
morbius